now doing when you do Caitlin and the
and the girls yeah but when you do the
girls right yeah how long does that take
if you go to everyone listening right
now oh yeah
follow Kyle Dunnigan right now Kyle
Dunnigan one is my handle is that it's
your verified correct yeah Kyle Dunnigan
not she's not putting out much comedy
yeah
but follow Kyle Dunnigan not one card
like that one yeah all right follow Kyle
Dunnigan one it's verified but he does
great impressions but you do how long
does it those videos say cuz it seems
like when I'm watching a girl just to
take took all day it used to take a long
time but what I'll do is I'll literally
write have to write out a script and
have like specific lines so when I film
it it's like I'll do the main person
first I get Caitlin's like talks the
most yeah I'll do that out and then I'll
email that to myself or airdrop it to my
computer and I'll turn it really low and
then I'll get dressed up as a different
woman yeah like Kim Kardashian yeah and
then I'll play that and I'll be able to
do my lines back and I'll be able to
hear but no one else can hear that I
could hear so I that syncs it up
perfectly Wow first one is the hardest
one to do and what I do is I mouth in my
mouth the other person's line so it's
like pretty dwell time downer oh so just
know that it's the time eeeh because in
my head I'm like god the timing must be
really difficult because not only you
have to wait for them to talk as well
the first time I did it was like five
hours I'd also to figure the editing I'm
getting a picture-in-picture and all
that stuff oh yeah and then those at
like to play Trump don't you just get
that through an app and yes yeah there's
like filters yeah the Kim Jong what do
you need kim jeong-hoon that was Kim
Jong yeah that's pretty racist
it was racist well how did you do what I
was worried about you Kanye yeah cuz I
was like you know oh you can do Kim
jong-un but not Kanye you [ __ ]
[ __ ] do I mean like society wise and
like sign anyone the blackface feel I
didn't want that
yeah you know thought so but but you
know it's his actual can you see white
Kanye just say do as we do a voice yeah
yeah maybe you could do that I don't
know well I did the Kanye no one no one
seemed to be offended so oh you already
did it yeah yeah oh you did it with
blackface
no it's filthy it's his face Kim's on my
face oh yeah yeah yeah I mean I don't
where's the line I don't know there is
no line because your intentions and
you're doing impressions I try to yeah I
played John McCain and [ __ ] MADtv oh
yeah
oh yeah yeah and not only did I do tell
me and McCain yeah mine was terrible I'm
not gonna do it but when they called me
to do John McCain I got yeah I can't do
it morally I can't do it and I go why I
could because we're the ones that [ __ ]
up his arms oh yeah he was captured by
Asians oh right we [ __ ] up his arms
for five years are you Vietnamese no but
you know I mean we're I'm Asian yeah
are you really he knows the difference
why'd you keep turning on the TV and
he's like oh my god one of them gooks is
playing why'd you [ __ ] his arms up yeah
he's like a good guy well he not only
that that we let him live
not we that's cool yeah he's big John
McCain fan your dog this is so you guys
you guys you guys it I don't know if
we've got given given away fritter yeah
but fruit is a great dog park yeah I
just can't with these many animals I
can't sleep good puppy this is a wild
puppy I know but you're like um what are
you tweeting man no I just
I actually thought of something which
was I should run them like I just
thought of like to send myself and I
forget which impressions I do and you
reminded me so sighs oh wow that forget
yeah yeah you do forget I love you hey I
like you yeah yeah I am falling in love
with you I feel myself falling yeah what
are you doing George you're [ __ ] it
up my cut my nephew said having a 1 in
having a number in your Instagram name
he's like 18 like it's not cool that way
you have a nephew
any dizzy follow it yeah yeah he's great
kid but he like lets me know what's cool
and what's not cool yeah
Kyle gonnigan one Bobby Lee yeah Bobby
Lee somebody what if I did that yeah
yeah I almost did Bobby Lea 7
not even for email addresses anymore I
didn't know that wasn't cool it's like I
think only 40 year olds and up do that
oh great what's under school wide when
did underscore happen underscore still
okay but what is it why did they do that
again because the non underscore is
taken
oh I'd change my name it'll screw
everything up why me you wouldn't lose
the followers right I don't know like
would you lose cuz people that have
verified I don't think you could change
your name yours yeah your know your for
Kyle Dunnigan number one whatever number
one yeah what is the number one one yet
you're Kyle Dunnigan one yeah
you can't change it who cares who gives
well my nephew I know but I'm just
saying though that it's like people are
finding it and if some douchebag out
there named Kyle Dunnigan already has
the name I mean there should be a thing
though we held on did you try writing
him and saying hey can I have can i buy
the name yeah maybe I should do that
because I tried with mine cuz there's a
kalila out there yeah and she has one
photo and she never responded oh let me
pay you and she would she's never
responded yeah there are Bobby Lee is
out there I just want to go just don't
even let it go there's like seven Kyle
Dunnigan in the world yeah well there's
so many but there's a steel guitarist a
white old man I love who's yeah he's a
he's a Bobby Lee he's pretty famous
yes booyah hit but if you google it must
drive him crazy because if you just put
Bobby Lee and yeah right it's the first
25 photos as me yeah yeah so it feels so
good it but I know that he googles it
right and he has to put some like a
tourist
right you can't just say his name so I
just you know I heard him every day I
believe mmm you know that feels good
yeah
[Music]